standard basis measurement on B and again this was covered in lesson two of the
series soose we did perform a standard basis measurement on B each possible outcome would then
appear with probability equal to the ukan norm squared of the corresponding Vector 5 b and conditioned on getting a
particular outcome B we normalize the vector 5B to determine the resulting state of
a following the same reasoning as in the ebit example from a few moments ago we obtain the expression shown on the
screen for the reduced state of a as a density Matrix and by the way the norm squared in the denominator comes from
multiplying the normalized vector to its conjugate transpose so we pick up the ukian norm twice in the
denominator the ukian Norms squared cancel and we're left with a pretty simple
expression and in fact if we substitute in our formula for 5B which works for every B we get a formula for the reduced
state of the system a in terms of the density Matrix description of the pure state that we started with namely csai
brasai so this is our formula for the reduced state of the system a supposing that the compound system AB started in
the pure State sigh but we can also use the formula more generally in particular let's suppose
that the state of ab is given by some density Matrix row which could take the form K SI brai for some Quantum State
Vector s but not necessarily it follows basically by linearity that the reduced state of a is
determined by the same formula as we had for Pure States except that we substitute whatever density Matrix row we
wish as a Shand notation it's pretty common that we denote this reduced state by whatever name we're using for the
density Matrix Row in this case but we put a subscript indicating the system that we're focusing on so row with a
subscript a means the reduced state of a when the compound system is in the the state row superscripts are also sometimes used
instead of subscripts it's basically just a personal preference and it means the same
thing we've been focusing on the system a just for Simplicity but we can also obtain the reduced state of the system B
analogously but where the formula is adapted in the natural way everything is symmetric here we're
essentially just exchanging the roles of A and B and in particular the sum ranges over the classical states of a this time
rather than b and in the formula on the screen we're assuming the classical State set of a is called
Sigma all of this generalizes in a pretty straightforward way to three or more systems for example if we have three
systems a b and c that are collectively in the state described by the density Matrix row then we can obtain the
reduced state of the pair a together by the formula that shown here as well as the state of the third system alone
which is the second formula and you can consider other combinations and generalize this to however many systems you wish the sums are always taken over
the classical State sets of the systems that are being ignored and the pattern is always the same with the density
Matrix we started with being sandwiched between the tensor product of the identity Matrix and bras and cats corresponding to standard basis
states to conclude the lesson I'll say just a a little bit more about the definitions we've just covered the operation on density
matrices that describes redu States has a name and it's called the partial trace for two systems A and B the
partial Trace over B and the partial Trace over a are as defined here on the screen these are exactly the same
formulas that we saw a few moments ago and now we're just thinking about them as functions of row and giving them
names the names look like the trace except that there's a subscript which tells us which system is being removed
or in other words which system is the one whose classical State set we're summing over and is getting sandwiched between a bra and a
cat when we take the partial trace of our B for instance which is described by the first Formula we sometimes say that
b is traced out and likewise for a intuitively speaking tracing out a
system just means that we throw it away or simply ignore it that's one way to define the partial
trace and another equivalent way is to say that these mappings are the unique linear mappings that satisfy the
formulas shown here on the right specifically if we have a tensor product of two matrices M and N let's
say and we perform the partial Trace over the first system then what we get is the trace of the first Matrix M times
the second Matrix and the condition is symmetric when we Trace over the second system not every Matrix that we would
compute the partial trace of is a tensor product like this but every Matrix can be expressed as a linear combination of
tensor products and we can determine the partial Trace from these conditions together with the fact that these are linear
functions and this is why it's called the partial trace this equivalent definition can be
quite helpful because we can often use it rather than the original formula here's an example that
illustrates this suppose that we have a pair of cubits a in the state whose density Matrix is shown here on the
screen this happens to be an example of a correlated state where a is either in the zero State or the one state each
with probability 1/2 so we can think about a as being classical if a is in the zero State then
so is B and if a is in the one state then B is in the plus state if we want to know what the reduced state of a is
we Trace out B and if we use the second formula from the equivalent definition together with linearity then we can
compute this pretty easily in particular the trace of k0 bra 0 is one as is the trace of K plus bra
plus so those tensor factors disappear and we're left with the completely mixed state along similar lines we can compute
the reduce state of B by tracing out a this time it's the first tensor factor that we're performing the trace on so
we're using the first Formula from the equivalent definition and we're left with 1/2 * cat 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 * cat
plus bra Plus or in other words the same density Matrix that came up a few times previously you would get exactly the
same results if you Ed the formulas from the first definition but this is a much easier way to do it this all generalizes to three or more
systems but for this video I'm going to stop here and leave this for you to consider on your own and that is it for this lesson which
is introduced density matrices and describe the basics of how they work we also discussed the block sphere
as well as different types of correlations and the notion of a reduced state of a system I hope you'll join me for the
next lesson which is about channels which are linear mappings from density matrices to density matrices that